so one word to describe Bernie Sanders
fairytale I think that Hillary Clinton
and Bernie Sanders have this vendetta
against Wall Street I'm a Republican I
think the only guy for the job is John
Kasich what do you think most people on
Wall Street think about Bernie Sanders I
don't think for attendance that's what I
thought as well but it actually turned
out to be pretty hard to find someone
who didn't agree with at least one of
Bernie's arguments I think the fact that
he has traction is only testament to the
fact that there enough thinking
Americans that realize Hillary Clinton
is a dangerous enemy do you think we
should break up the big banks as we said
you know what happened to what get you
know okay no doubt you know they're
contributed to it
they're like the subway on the right is
getting real the banks are screwing you
what do you think about the fact that
there's a revolving door between
Washington and Wall Street I've had the
unfortunate privilege of lobbying in
Washington the most disgusting things
I've ever done in my life
it's was absolutely horrible that I a
personal friend of mine it was the
congressman the only way we got it to
see them as if we came with a check I
met up with wade black chief operating
officer of scarsdale entities who's a
so-called banker for Bernie he's even
contributed to his campaign one of the
things that people questioned me about a
lot is that you know what buddy how do
you feel about his attacks on Wall
Street as you know a thing to attack and
you know I'm I think that's a it's a
rhetorical device it's not not
I'm not feeling personally attacked by
by Bernie Sanders I think you know it's
it's it's going after the bad elements
so you're not offended as someone whose
parents know they deserve it who think
that the members of the my industry
you're not taking into account your own
self-interest here to a degree I think I
am because I think in the long run you
know the country is better off as a more
just and equitable economy for everyone